un air de déjà vu à djibouti comme en
1999 et 2011
seuls deux candidats sont en lice pour
la présidentielle
sans surprise le chef de l'état sortant
ismaël omar guelleh a toutes les chances
de remporter ce scrutin
l'inamovible leader de ce petit pays de
la corne de l'afrique se présente pour
un cinquième mandat après 22 ans au
pouvoir
ismaël omar guelleh a décidé de rempiler
même si l'annoncé plusieurs fois sa
volonté de passer la main une longévité
politique qui rend fier certains de ses
partisans
on est fiers parce qu'on voit le
développement qui leur envoient les
efforts qu'il fournit au pays le prat
sur le patriotisme tout ou tousser c'est
un tout on a ainsi c'est le seul
précédent qu'on veut garder qu'on peut
avoir et qu'on veut avoir pour un
nouveau mandat le président est génial
il fait beaucoup de choses pour notre
pays
il apporte des investissements il
développe le pays avec de nombreux
nouveaux projets et infrastructures
je suis impatiente on est fiers nous
avons un énorme sentiment de fierté et
nous avons pleine confiance en notre
président on aura encore une meilleure
journée électorale que la fois
précédente 1 est fier de lui et on aime
tant qu'il contient et pour un nouveau
mandat face au président sortant zakaria
ismaili farah qui se présente en
indépendant
un entrepreneur inconnu du grand public
jusqu'à sa déclaration de candidature
l'opposition qui contestent le processus
électoral a quant à elle boycotté ce
scrutin
trois partis politiques le mouvement
armé fruges quatre ong et une douzaine
d'activistes ont signé une charte pour
une transition démocratique
les élections ne sert plus à rien à
djibouti et donc plus le pouvoir
s'éternise plus les risques de chaos et
d'instabilité seront présents la raison
pour laquelle nous avons organisé cette
charte de transition
c'est pour empêcher le chaos dès la
chute du pouvoir cette charte doit
s'appliquer
et comme geel et ne partira pas de
lui-même nous construisons un rapport de
force par des luttes multiformes pour le
dégager en l'absence des leaders
historiques de l'opposition les chances
de zakaria ismail farah
son maigre il faut dire que le président
sortant a remporté avec plus de 75% des
voix
chaque présidentielle à laquelle il a
participé si ismaël omar guelleh
âgé de 73 ans est réélu président ce
cinquième mandat pourrait être le
dernier pour lui puisque la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2010 a instauré une
limite d'âge à 75 ans